hmm
[Music]
what's up y'all what's what's what's
hmm let me tell you something what's up
y'all
what up so they are introducing
core the god butcher
and the fantastic four into the mcu
hype is real the hype
is real moriah
the hype is real is the hype not real
mariah
it's very real i'm very excited right
like as soon as i heard the news i was
upstairs laying in bed with my girl
and and i got and like like the news
dropped i was looking i was looking on
twitter
and people were like christian bale was
playing gore the god butcher in the mcu
and i was like
what and then and then like there was a
whole bunch of other announcements where
it was like they announced the fantastic
four movie and john watts is the one
directing it right john watch direct to
spider-man
and i was like so you're telling me the
announce score the god butcher and the
fantastic four are going to be in the
marvel cinematic universe
song look here's here's here's here's
the thing man let me let me close the
story
let me close the story let me tell you
awesome man
let me tell you all right
all you people out there who don't read
comics y'all are not ready
y'all are not ready for for the
greatness that is gonna that is gonna
befall
the marvel cinematic universe so let's
let's start with glory the god butcher
all right let's let's let's let's start
with
the god butcher right this dude this
dude is an absolute monster right so
gord the god butcher was this guy who
was on this world where it was like a
really really harsh environment
and like his his tribe would pray to
pray to the gods all the time and like
the gods would never answer like he lost
his wife and his child all that kind of
stuff
it was a really crappy existence right
so like these two gods fell from the sky
one of which was this guy named null who
like defeated the celestials basically
at some point online
but he had the sword called the
all-black necro sword
so gore the god butcher and being pissed
off at like the fact that the gods
always ignore them decides to go on a
crusade
against the god so he takes he takes the
all black necro sword
and then like recresses himself gore the
god butcher and then like just goes
across the universe
killing every god he can find right so
he arrives on earth like a few thousand
years ago he fights thor for the first
time
beats his ass like beats the hell out of
thor right i mean just
i mean just just not even in hell would
you see a massacre like what happened
when he go to the god butcher beat the
hell out of four you know what i'm
saying like it was
it was just it was it was it was just it
was he was not prepared man
that's all it was so so gorgeous you
know thor gets gets just readily crushed
by gore right and
then the gorgeous vanishes again so then
like thor in the present day ends up
facing off against gore and i think he
loses
and so what you end up finding out is
that gore had actually like in the
future
gore had like conscripted all these gods
that he didn't kill
to his cause in order to create this god
bomb because he was gonna basically
detonate this bomb in the time stream
and kill all the gods at once right from
the past the present and the future
so it takes thor from the past thor from
the present and four in the future right
old king thor who like defeated galactus
it took like all of them working
together to defeat gore
and then it all came down to modern day
thor who takes the all-black necro sword
and
two mjolnirs and then he overpowers gore
and then manages to beat him right
guy had to wield two hammers to beat
gore man two hammers
right like that's that's what that's
that's it's it's
nuts man like gordon dude here's the
thing though the god butcher was like
the coolest villain
ever right you guys ever get a chance
there's a video on my channel uh here on
comments explain
it's basically jason aaron's uh thor god
of thunder we cover the whole story arc
with gore right and it's like the
coolest thing
it's just this amazing story but like
gore is he's just such and such like an
amazing and awesome
character but this is a guy who just
crushed thor
like multiple times and i don't mean
just like oh man you know like he got a
couple hits it's not like a high school
fight right we're like you know you got
like one more hit than the other guys so
like you won
no no this is like this this this this
this was thor never had a chance man
that's that's that's what that was like
thor
never never like in the first time they
fought thor never had a chance
right like it was it was just it was
and then we then we got the fantastic
four right here's the thing
if we get fantastic four if we get
fantastic four we need jonathan
hickman's fan
we we need jonathan hate with fantastic
four son i wanna see jonathan what's
fantastic four
i'm tired of seeing like those terrible
fox
fan four stick i'm tired of seeing those
stupid fox fantastic four movies i want
to see
jonathan hickman's fantastic four son
jonathan hayek's fantastic four here's
why jonathan hickman's fantastic four is
so cool right so
reed richards has this son named
franklin and franklin is like this
reality warping kid right just
and i'll you'll see i'll tell you listen
let me
tell you something i'll tell you
something in a minute right how powerful
this kid is right i'm sorry i'm so
excited people
but it is a really it's an exciting time
right so so
here's what happens right so like
franklin richards when he was younger
reed richards put these mental blocks in
place so he couldn't use his powers why
did we richards do that
because there was a story where franklin
richards was watching he was playing
with a rubik's cube and then there was a
tv in the background it was like it was
something like why don't you grow up
so franklin richards used his like
universal wide reality warping powers to
turn himself into jesus
and then like just started running amok
right so like once they got him back to
normal he literally turned into he
looked like jesus man
like he's all dressed in white with like
this long hair like he
looks like he looks he looks like jesus
right like he looks like marvel's jesus
so so um so reed is like okay my kid's
too powerful we gotta
keep this kind of under check under
control right so um
you go into john and i think that's
fantastic four and like this grown guy
appears out of nowhere right like this
this just grow this grown man like
just shows up in the backstreet building
out of nowhere and like starts making
his way
towards the kid's rooms right to
franklin richard's room and valeria
richards she's the daughter of reed and
susan of mr and mrs fantastic
she's like super smart she's like the
third smartest person in the world
but uh but they but he starts making his
way towards their room and like the
fantastic four start freaking out right
they're like man dude what do we do man
like what do we do you know there's this
weird man who broke into our house and
he's heading towards our kids rooms
right like you know
any responsible parent we go with guns
and like we would probably shoot him you
know because whatever
and so like it's like they go running
towards running towards this guy this
guy looks at him and just like creates
this forcefield they can't get past
right susan storm
she was able to create force fields that
could withstand the blast of celestials
and she couldn't even get through it
right it's like this guy was obviously
not not messing around
so he grabs franklin and then like like
he he like whispers something to him or
something like that and then franklin
drops on the ground and passes out right
and then he says something to valeria
and then leaves right
so you get towards you get like this
this whole crazy story going on
where like reed richards goes to this
place called the nexus where it's like
all these alternate reality versions of
like mr fantastic like
one has the infinity like i think three
of them had the infinity gauntlets and
then like there's someone like their
powers are switched so like reed
richards has the power of like
the silver surfer or something like that
well what they do is they solve the
problem of
everything right like that's their whole
goal like they just fix problems so like
there's a whole universe out there
where all they do is grow food and then
they just like take it to universes
where food is is not that not that
prevalent right it's like the coolest
thing ever right so
um so one of the reeds ends up going to
this alternate reality where the
celestials went crazy
and basically forced everybody to
worship them as gods and like when he
came back to the nexus the celestials
followed him back so it's like oh dude
this is kind of crazy man like
this this is wild so so like the
celestials break into this whole place
right just like this guy's like dude
they follow me and they're like oh my
god we gotta we gotta run right so like
the infinity gauntlets don't work
because the infinity gauntlets only work
in their own universes and they're not
inside their own universes they're in
like this
kind of hub where like all the universes
connect right you would think it works
it doesn't work so like these celestials
just come pouring in right and just
start killing
everybody so like reed richards from the
main novel universe is like dude man we
gotta get out of here right so like he
bails
he goes and grabs some giant gun and
comes back and then like like they fight
the celestials off
and like for the most parts they saved
and it's like cool all right this is
awesome
so then like what you end up finding out
is the celestials followed reed richards
to the main marvel universe and so
there's this point where like
reed richards meets with galactus right
and galactus is like dude we need to
talk about your son we need to talk
about franklin because his powers have
woken up again right that's something
that's like in the background
franklin power franklin richards powers
wake back up and galactus is
legitimately scared he's like dude
your son's powers have woken back up man
and like it scares the hell out of me so
it's like
damn son right like why this is a
[ __ ] galactus man
galaxy's afraid of this guy so it's like
okay like like something's gonna happen
with franklin
so so the mad celestials followed read
back well then like valeria their
daughter from the future shows up and
tells susan storm hey like things are
gonna pop off
uh just so you know like things are
gonna really really you know really
really dire
when that happens have hope the day will
be safe so you're like okay cool
so so anyway so the mad celestials show
up to earth with the intention of like
killing reed richards
and then like subjugating that whole
universe and and so like
reed summons galactus to earth and like
galactus faces off against
uh damn it
and like galactus faces off against all
the celestials and uh and
and then like ends up being defeated
right the celestial's like merged into
one big celestial unless so he ends up
being defeated
and so it's just kind of like damn son
right like galactus is basically dead
like they kill it right so it's like
damn
so like they start they you know like
reed richards and vince's weapon called
like saul's anvil
which is designed to like just shoot
energy at celestials and destroy them
and like they like it ends up like he
fires it off once which breaks the
celestials back into
their three parts again and then like um
and then like like wallace charging up
the celestial's attack right so like
susan storm is sitting there like
holding her force field up she's got her
shield up and like the celestials are
just like hammered like they're just
they're just like you know hammering
down hellfire right boom boom boom right
there
there's just it's like the end times
right like they're just hammering down
[ __ ] on susan's store
and she's just sitting there holding as
best she can and then like the words of
her daughter come up right like when
things are at their darkest like have
hope and the day will be saved and like
up in the sky this light comes out of
nowhere
and it's like who in the hell is that
and it's franklin richards and valeria
from the future
and what you end up finding out is that
franklin richards from the future went
to the past to walk his
wake his powers up right so so like he's
the man that showed up in the fantastic
forest building
and so so like he'd been teaching
himself his younger self how to use his
abilities
and it's like damn son like like so what
he ends up doing is is his younger self
just kept all his power
didn't really use it all but he just
kind of stored it all up he combines it
with the power of his older self right
so like adult franklin richards is the
guy who's fighting he goes to goliath
he's like there's there's the most it's
the most amazing moment ever in the
history
there's the most amazing moment in
history comics like like like
literally franklin like takes this ball
of energy out of him and like throws it
in the galactus and he's like
and he's like to me my galactus and like
rhetoric galactus from the dead
and like makes him his herald and it's
like the most it's the most beast [ __ ]
ever right so so like galactus is like
fighting these celestials and like
franklin richards is fighting the
celestials they managed to destroy him
right and it's just like damn you know
and so it's like it's like the most
beast thing ever right we need that in
the mcu man like tell me that does not
sound legit
like it's it's it's amazing it's amazing
but anyway
uh it's awesome news right i'm probably
never gonna be able to sleep again now
because i'm i'm super excited i got
myself so hyped up
but uh this is it's it's me it's gonna
be exciting it's gonna be super exciting
so
anyway guys uh we're gonna bring this
video to an end and uh
yeah man i'll catch you guys later
peace